I got another big idea let's get AMC to
put a theater in decentraland what if
they not only got into online in a big
way but still kept the spirit of
physically going to the theaters and
hanging out with friends they can sell
tickets that you can buy using Mana
users would be able to walk to a pizza
kiosk and order a pizza and then go to
theater and hang out with their friends
and watch a movie together all without
leaving their house and the game and it
it's happening someone built a theater
yo AMC where you at you don't want to
miss this opportunity
man when I walked in it blew my mind
something was playing I watched it for
at least five minuets sound and video
was clear as [__] checked it out and it
blew me away this is absolutely sick who
owns it this will be awesome once VR is
integrated and you can do screen sharing
with a group of friends so it'll be like
watching the movie together I could even
see decentral and movie gift cards being
sold at the supermarket in the area
where all those gift cards are located
better be so cool
I wish could take all my Bitcoin and
live inside this world
dope ass clap clap clap clap clap clap
thumbs up okay high five 100 100.
[Music]
what you're looking at is decentraland
conceived by Argentine developers as to
Banner Dano and Ari Malek as a virtual
reality world for unconstrained markets
and presently advertising itself as a
decentralized metaverse owned by its
users in the pitch version decentraland
is a true virtual space a whole new
parallel world that you access via
virtual reality a world where you can
shop buy things invest purchase goods
and go to stores unconstrained by the
laws that govern the place where your
physical body eats and sleeps a product
so promising that it commands a
valuation in the billions of dollars in
practice it's just a bad video game made
up of smaller worse video games wrapped
in a real estate scheme cosplaying as
the Matrix most of what decentraland
does and what it fails to do are things
that would be considered forgivable or
acquaint in a Kickstarter MMO that had
clearly bitten off more than the
creators could ever chew but given that
this is a project founded on
cryptocurrency all of those foibles are
laced with the language of finance and
landlordism strolling down decentraland
spacious boulevards at five frames per
second rewards the user with a seemingly
endless parade of virtual Billboards
brightly proclaiming that the space you
see is all available to rent this is
because of a pretty basic chain of
incentives that are laid bare by
decentraland's history while the
nominally playable game launched in
February 2020 the actual launch was in
2017 broken into two parts first an
initial coin offering in August where
their Mana token sales raised
approximately 24 million dollars
denominated in crypto coins and second
with the terraforming event where
Parcels of land denominated in land
tokens were auctioned off for an
additional 28 million in crypto
predominantly bought by guys like this
I've not said it until it's worth at
least 10 million this being crypto the
obsession with scarcity is so pervasive
that it's almost a waste of time to even
mention it but the land tokens were
limited to ninety thousand which of
course centered a lot of the discussion
of decentraland around the hypothetical
value of the virtual plots of land in
the event the decentraland won the
future and became the Manhattan of the
metaverse the go-to destination for
virtual life the initial buyers plans
for the land overwhelmingly veered
towards pitching cryptocurrency or
financial services or just sitting on
the land with the intent of renting it
out later this is all baked in
decentraland's initial pitch hinges on
it what if you could own the virtual
world
create develop and trade Without Limits
make genuine connections
and earn real money
decentral end a fully immersive platform
powered by the blockchain
by land
[Music]
your experience
and transform the way people see the
world
purchase the Free first ever virtual
real estate get started today
now there's a lot of ground that needs
to be covered and a not insubstantial
amount of theory that I would like to
get out there but I suspect the main
thing you might be here for is failure
so just to wet your appetite here is a
list of things you can expect to see as
we talk about decentraland what it is
and what it isn't
the central land records presents the
only collection of failure You'll Ever
Need
Graphics or performance dead Mall Vines
missing geometry weed leaves loading
boxes and so much more
but before we can get into that we've
got to talk about the metaverse
[Music]
in the past two years you have likely
been inundated with attempts to explain
and Define the metaverse and yet despite
the numerous numerous attempts you
probably feel no closer to having an
actual workable definition in your head
one that maps to something you can
visualize actually integrating with your
life there are a lot of definitions out
there most of them are incredibly flimsy
many of them are outright insane very
few agree on anything other than the
broad strokes and almost all of them
fall back on gesturing towards Ready
Player one and going you know that thing
it'll be like that in the mainstream the
metaverse has been somewhat hijacked by
the crypto and web 3 crowd an
interesting element to that is that
while they are extremely aggressively
pushing the word metaverse out into the
public Consciousness they are late
arriving parasites they will typically
nod their heads at any metaverse Vision
before throwing it back at you with
their crypto junk grafted onto it they
don't care about the form or content of
the metaverse but both crypto and the
metaverse require spontaneous Mass
adoption to make sense ends so the two
are somewhat simpatico in that regard in
sharp contrast we have the writing of
Ryan Bulger a theologian bulger's vision
of the metaverse is that of a reified
space that sits on top of the real world
a one-to-one digital clone you can leave
a digital letter for someone on a park
bench and they need to go to that same
bench to find it a clone so accurate
that self-driving cars will navigate not
via sensors that monitor the world
around them but by referencing the
current position of things in the
metaverse the most jacked version of
Google Maps you can imagine for Bulger
traditional websites and apps are just a
stop Gap to the ultimate aim which
should be to astrally project via VR
into a McDonald's where a cashier will
then see you through AR glasses and take
your order as if you were in the space
the goal of this degree of ramification
was to create a space so real and
legitimate that it could be said that
the metaverse could be capable of
containing Divinity a church in the
metaverse can be sacred independent of
the context of human interaction because
it's not just software it's a place
digital fashion and other vegetal
Industries also want to break down the
barrier between physical and digital but
for very different reasons they look at
the market for cosmetics and live
service video games and crave
Translating that business model to
reality rather than building a rarefied
virtual world digital fashion is much
more interested in the augmented reality
side of things they want AR glasses that
are so Universal and so seamless that we
all dress in mocap suits and composite
the new Gucci over it using an advanced
spin on tick tock's hat filter in this
definition the metaverse isn't another
place conceptual or otherwise it's just
a name for the digital skin that gets
laid over the world when viewed through
compatible devices we strongly believe
that the amount of clothing produced
today is way greater than Humanity needs
but don't shop less up digital fashion
don't shop less don't shop less don't
don't you don't you dare don't you dare
shop less don't you there are numerous
problems here which boil down to the
fact that all of these have equal claim
to the word metaverse if you comb
through dozens and dozens of definitions
of the metaverse you can assemble a web
of broad attributes where some are
generally agreed upon While others
border on being mutually exclusive it's
a vague largely incoherent cloud of
ideas that's malleable enough that
basically anything can be called part of
the metaverse a Proto metaverse or a
semi-metaverse the central land is the
metaverse the sandbox is the metaverse
Horizon worlds is the metaverse Roblox
is the metaverse fortnite is the
metaverse Minecraft is the metaverse the
lint experience is the metaverse I look
at my 14 year old and she has spent the
last year and a half living in diverse
she doesn't even know that word right
but her school is on Zoom she hangs out
with her friends online in one form or
another actually in a whole bunch of
different forms right in Instagram in
Tick Tock in iMessage in in fortnite in
um Animal Crossing in uh you know in all
of these different you know metaverses
right
the virtual world space such as Tim
Sweeney believe that eventually every
company will need to operate their own
virtual worlds both as Standalone
planets and is part of leading virtual
world platforms such as fortnite and
Minecraft as Sweeney has put it just as
every company a few decades ago created
a web page and then at some point every
company created a Facebook page of
course this flexibility that allows for
anything good and popular to be part of
a natural inevitable precursor to the
true metaverse simultaneously provides
the flexibility to dismiss any failure
as a failing of that pure Vision rather
than a failure of the underlying ideas
themselves the metaverse cannot fail you
can only fail to make the metaverse
there is no consensus definition because
the metaverse isn't real it's not an
actual thing that anyone's really
building it's a rhetorical device that
allows the writer to gesture at the
future and pontificate on what ought to
be definitions of the metaverse are
thusly principally rooted in the
writer's prayer present political and
social values when you understand that
the metaverse isn't a distinct invention
or construct but merely a rhetorical
proxy for the future of technology then
all of this becomes a lot easier to deal
with the reason it's also messy is
because of the aforementioned gesturing
towards fiction and because a lot of the
people writing effluent prose about how
the future is here today in the form of
blockchain based social spaces are for
the most part salesmen that's not to say
that they don't believe the metaverse
could or should exist just that most
have not considered if it would actually
be any good that part they take is a
given because it's always super cool in
stories so why even bother considering
that the end result might be boring
inconvenient and disappointing now
science fiction and actual science have
a long and storied history it's fun to
point to all the devices that exist
today that were first sketched out by a
fiction writer decades earlier but
there's all also a massive survivorship
bias there sure some speculations become
real either because the author rooted
their speculation in cutting-edge
science or because fans of the work
tried extremely hard to make it a
reality but even more get discarded as
silly useless impractical deadly or
physically impossible this might come as
a shock but when a writer sits down to
compose fiction the thing that they
write doesn't need to actually work
they're not real inventions they're
narrative devices and at a certain point
no amount of cool Factor can make up for
the limitations of physical space Star
Trek's Holodeck is an insanely cool idea
and dear God do I wish it were real but
it can't exist not as depicted because
it's not an invention it's a collection
of camera tricks and special effects at
the end of the day the holodex
limitations and lack thereof are
dictated by narrative necessity so when
Neil Stevenson writes about the
metaverse in snow crash in 1992 you it
is an invention composed of a mix of
speculation about the future of existing
Hardware Trends in how people interact
via virtual spaces and an overwhelmingly
cartoonish dose of rule of cool
Stevenson's metaverse is a massive
three-dimensional contiguous space
because it's evocative and interesting
it provides a colorful backdrop for the
story's Gonzo plot about a high-stakes
pizza delivery swordmaster employed by
the mafia and a computer virus that can
cause brain damage snow crash is
prescient in degrees about some of the
ways in which we would engage with
technology but overwhelmingly that
prescience applies to the internet as it
currently exists we have virtual Live
Events virtual Sports virtual Town
squares virtual clubhouses and even
virtual strip clubs where you can hang
out in chat with 500 strangers and watch
someone just absolutely
really the only things that are missing
are either aesthetic like the giant
contiguous three-dimensional
representation of the internet where you
can walk from one web page to the next
or maybe not even physically possible at
all like the snow crash virus itself so
this then creates a bit of a trap for a
lot of the salesmen writing about the
inevitability of the metaverse where
they have to cling to those aesthetic
details as non-negotiable because
otherwise they're just
talking about the internet as Matthew
ball writes in his 2022 book The
metaverse and how it will change
everything although Virtual Worlds come
in many dimensions 3D is a critical
specification for the metaverse without
3D we might as well be describing the
current Internet message boards chat
services website Builders image
platforms and interconnected networks of
content have been around and popular for
decades after all which brings us to
Virtual Reality VR is pretty cool Tech I
really like it it's also pretty limited
or more specifically the tech runs up
against a pretty big barrier which is
the human body the inner ear really
doesn't like moving without actually
moving which means that every VR
application is a series of compromises
between the immersive potential of VR
and what the body will tolerate No oh
God oh God because Stevenson's metaverse
is a plot device effectively an
alternate Dimension the characters are
able to navigate the space however
Stevens and wants them to and because
it's narratively interesting when the
characters want to get from one part of
the metaverse to another they need to
Traverse the distance between those two
points ball for his part concedes the
users of the inevitable metaverse would
likely find this to be too inconvenient
and prefer to teleport from location to
location the reality is even more
restrictive the compromise is that
overwhelmingly virtual reality
experiences are largely static
experiences with freeform movement
around a small footprint with the user
teleporting from spot to spot even
within the same virtual room it's a
compromise that VR enthusiasts are
willing to accept because the
alternative is a one-way trip to the
floor as your cochlea decides that being
upright is no longer an option the end
result the actuality of virtual reality
is that it's an incredibly potent tool
for an unfortunately limited number of
applications this creates a very sharp
contrast between the metaverse that's
talk about by pundits and the reality of
VR the developers and enthusiasts have
been mapping for over a decade with
pundits continuing to insist that a vast
contiguous space representing the
internet is not only a desirable way to
interact with those functionalities but
indeed a preferential way how this
manifests is a metaverse that exists
overwhelmingly in the form of blog posts
about the inevitability of its existence
with anything tangentially related to
Virtual Reality being encircled as part
of the metaverse along with a whole lot
of stuff hardly related at all a
particular Fascination is the way that
this is all talk and no product lint USA
manufactures of terrible chocolate
truffles launched their metaverse store
in November 2022 and just have a look at
the language used to describe it
lint USA launches its first ever 3D
virtual store with Beyond XR and makes
shopping for premium chocolate a truly
Innovative experience
in a beautifully decorated fully 3D and
highly photorealistic environment the
store welcomes visitors with an engaging
introduction by one of Lynn's famous
Master chocolatiers and shaja best of
all the immersive store is totally
comprehensible we at lint USA are
thrilled to offer customers this
state-of-the-art experience just in time
for the holidays while there is no
experience like walking into one of our
beautiful lint stores in person our
online store is no different we're
excited to show it off this is all
pretty routine corporate fluff though
the surprising and telling thing is that
it's just words there's few if any
images included and there's a reason why
the whole of it is elevated to
transcendental when you see the actual
thing that they're describing a laggy
hideous cheap faux 3D website that would
probably be a camp hit if it were
pitched instead as a throwback to FMV
video games from the 90s
of course you do the vast majority of
these so-called metaverse offerings are
virtual spaces only insofar as they are
painted to resemble a store we already
tried this 25 years ago and discarded it
because it turns out the human brain can
shop from a list of items or a grid of
photos far better than it can from an
image map photo of a display case
examples like this portray not only the
ignorance of history on the part of the
particle pushing it but also a profound
incompetence on the part of the people
building it rather than being a Cutting
Edge virtual shopping experience the
lint store is so bad so embarrassing
that it would be more respectable to
learn that Beyond XR is an outright scam
shaking down gullible corporations
afraid of being out of touch with the
future or missing the boat on the next
big thing rather than True Believers
trying their hardest the fact that
Patrick diggleman Vice President of
Sales and e-commerce for lint USA looked
at this final product and didn't
immediately scrap it bury it and demand
the company's money back is just a nice
tight encapsulation of how how much
metaverse participation is being driven
by irrational uninformed fomo and this
brings us back to decentraland all these
definitions are pretty bad for
decentraland it clearly wants to be the
metaverse it calls itself fat but
because they like lint have made the
mistake of actually trying to make
something it's possible to evaluate
whether or not they've succeeded they
have activated the Trap card of
falsifiability VR was dropped from
decentraland's core feature set
somewhere in 2018 or 2019 and has all
but officially been relegated to a
community-produced mod which just means
that it's difficult to get working in
the first place and when you do nothing
is optimized for VR either in terms of
technical performance or user experience
the results are dizzying even without a
headset on
ha
okay so the app's just uh straight up
broken now
cool
[Music]
for many definitions of the metaverse
like ball this already makes DCL a
non-starter virtual reality or at the
very least augmented reality is a
non-negotiable feature this however in
my evaluation is just a case of no true
metaverse decentraland is embarrassing
which makes it inconvenient which means
there's a lot of incentive to discredit
it as a claim to the idea of the
metaverse to insist that its failures
are meaningless that there's nothing to
learn from them about the viability of
the underlying ideas but the knife that
says all these definitions are the
metaverse cuts both ways if the concept
is so broad as to be little more than a
vague gesture at the future if
successful and popular things like
Minecraft and Roblox and fortnite get to
be the nascent metaverse then this does
too and if this is the future then the
future is a dead Mall foreign
it is difficult to fully encapsulate the
sheer contradiction between decentraland
as it exists in the minds of its
supporters and the actual product that
you can interact with but in this
endeavor we shall strive maybe we spent
our best shot early by opening with
redditors praising a theater with
non-functional doors and a photo of a
real concession stand in place of any
actual modeling but it's probably best
to let you know what you're in for that
post we ran earlier by the buy is the
most popular post of all time on the
decentraland subreddit the fact that
it's a crossover event with reddit's
meme stock Fanatics right down to being
disproportionately Laden with Reddit
Awards as they tend to do has a poetry
to it that I couldn't script name a more
iconic Duo than bad products and serial
bag holders you can't do it
the pizza kiosk they Rave about where
you could in theory order dominoes via
the metaverse and pay in eth or Mana is
long gone All That Remains is an empty
plot devoid of even the world's
procedurally generated Shrubbery the
details are thin but from what's
available it's apparent that Domino's
wasn't officially involved in any
capacity which would indicate that the
Builder had really just created a
middleman between you and dominoes where
he would take your crypto and then pass
the order along with payment in dollars
to Dominoes on your behalf the event
calls back to one of the foundational
myths of crypto the 10 000 Bitcoin Pizza
the first purchase ever made with
cryptocurrency
22nd of May 2010
is the date when someone first purchased
an item with Bitcoin in this case a
pizza the reality of that is very
similar to the decentraland pizza kiosk
no vendor accepted Bitcoin in exchange
for pizza Floridian laszlohanyats
offered 10 000 Bitcoin on a form to
anyone who would bring him two large
pizzas fellow Floridian Jeremy
sturdevent took him up on the offer
bought two large pizzas from a pizzeria
with his own money and then traded them
to Laszlo in exchange for the Bitcoin
hey that's backwards
wait it's also backwards from this side
other groups have tried to recreate
amusement rides in decentraland such as
those found in District X originally
slated to be decentraland's red light
district before the project organizer
stole all the donated land District X is
now home to an excellent Showcase of the
reality of decentralized ability to
deliver interactive experiences laggy
glitchy and profoundly sad
oh yes I can feel the Thrills coursing
through my veins in the decentraland
experience there's a persistent tension
between the different vectors of
incompetence most of the people building
this stuff don't have good ideas so the
stuff is generally bad from first
principles but then on top of that the
tools for building things in
decentraland are also bad so good ideas
are kneecapped by being extremely hard
to implement but then on top of that
decentraland just runs and performs
poorly the controls are particularly
heinous and sometimes the camera gets
possessed by a thousand angry ghosts so
no matter what experience you build
it'll be tainted by that mandatory
membrane of interaction
some of what you'll stumble across is
almost quaint like this modern style
Suburban single-family home populated
entirely by official Nintendo art it's
almost adorably incompetent like the
decentraland version of a geocity shrine
to Xander from Buffy the Vampire Slayer
at least until you notice the for sale
sign out front and the several dozen
identical Mario houses scattered around
the world all owned by the same guy
named Dan they're everywhere I've
completely lost track of how many unique
instances of this house I've stumbled
across this is in part because
navigating decentraland is a nightmare
the extremely short draw distance in
attendant lack of landmarks makes it
very easy to get lost so it's hard to
tell if any given modern Mario house is
a fresh one you've never been to before
or one that you've looped back on
August 1st 2022 announcements
decentually setting the track for future
experience creators using Infinity
engine code the first of its kind into
Central and decentrali shows what the
infinity engine code can do serving as
an open source foundation for future
high-speed experiences the central land
faces a fascinating problem inherent to
its basic construction the language of
interaction with the world of
decentraland is the language of games
you navigate the world via an avatar
your avatar runs jumps and clicks on
things this makes games the most obvious
implementation as an experience since
the ludology is already there the
problem is that decentraland is just bad
for games decentrali is an abysmal
little experience barely qualifying as
the Kart Racer that it nominally
resembles of course we can't judge it
too harshly as it's just a proof of
concept though given that everything in
decentraland seems to fall under that
umbrella it's enough to make one
suspicious like maybe it's still in Bay
data or it's just a proof of concept or
just a rhetorical Shield against
criticism either which way the
developer's other project Infinity
engine is also awful and it's being
featured onto centralland's front page
for well over a year
the fantasy of the metaverse is one
where it subsumes much of our present
reality where in the words of Matthew
ball entire Generations will eventually
move to and live inside it which as a
statement more or less demands poetic
interpretation that ball is referring to
interactions and activity taking place
via the membrane of the software because
otherwise it's you know stupid because
your body won't fit inside the wires but
regardless this idea of place requires
the simulacrum of place and the
simulacrum of place must Encompass both
the fantastic and the mundane because if
it doesn't Encompass both Skyrim and
your office and the grocery store then
there's too much discontinuity the
metaverse ceases to be a world a true
place and becomes little more than a
digital interface and to that end the
existence of the metaverse demands the
existence of issue law a professional
Corporation
welcome to the metaverse law office of
James issue a personal injury lawyer
based in Los Angeles James isn't in
right now no one is and he never will be
because the idea of Staffing this place
with actual people is patently absurd
well it was unfortunate that you tripped
and dropped the urn containing your
grandmother's ashes because you tripped
over a rake that your roommate left out
unfortunately when you attacked him with
that rake it was a crime and so I'm
afraid I'm going to have to refer you to
to a criminal defense lawyer this is
this is outside kind of the purview of
what I what I do
um I'm more of a personal injury lawyer
so um unfortunately you're going to uh
you are going to need a criminal defense
representation and I do have some people
that I can I can refer for you too I'm
I'm deeply sorry for the loss of your
grandmother
um and and the the death of your
roommate
um but I I can't assist you any further
in in this matter
this is not meaningfully useful in any
way to businesses when confronted with
the actual product the actual series of
things that would need to be engaged
with to make the fictional vision of the
metaverse real the product and the
comparison to the next generation of the
internet is comical Ball quotes Tim
Sweeney talking about a future where
every company is expected to operate a
virtual world just as every company a
few decades ago created a web page and
then at some point every company created
a Facebook page but here's the thing we
already know from those examples that
most companies don't need much more to a
website than some cursory fluff and
their contact information a website to
most companies is just a replacement for
a Yellow Pages entry it's an ad whose
number one job is to carry a phone
number address and business hours a
Facebook page became appealing because
it offloaded the work of Designing the
page and its functionality as a whole in
a way that office workers could easily
manage Facebook handles running Facebook
you just put in your stuff making it a
useful tool for high density up-to-date
communication like promotions or changes
in operating hours the entire process
there is a move towards efficiency the
construction and maintenance of a
virtual world is ludicrous in comparison
the effort to build and update is orders
of magnitude Beyond even a basic web
page and the information density goes
down like this is really important most
business communication is going to be in
the form of text for ever because text
is really really really useful but the
metaverse is a uniquely terrible medium
for the delivery of text because that
text cannot be presented in an optimized
format it must be bent to the metaphor
of a real space that's why the only
actual meaningful things in issue law a
professional Corporation are links to
Conventional flat text and image based
websites because they're just more
efficient ways to present and access
information so the virtual workspace the
idea that this plot in decentraland
would ever become actually functional as
a space with the receptionist navigating
up of the virtual stairs to tell James
via in-world voice chat that someone is
waiting to see him is comical but
without that promise without that story
what's even left an nft gallery and hard
to use widgets that just open Instagram
in another tab to remind you that you're
not in the metaverse you're just
browsing a website
I guess at least you can stand on the
balcony and admire the modern Mario
house across the street
even official production stuff created
by the developers themselves or people
they've subcontracted Trend heavily
towards embarrassing the festival stage
for the first annual metaverse Music
Festival featuring DJ Paris Hilton
lacked Collision on the stairs and
balcony meaning you could take a
terrible elevator to a second floor that
you would immediately fall through New
Year's Eve 2022 was staged in a Duke
nukemess Recreation of Times Square and
featured a devastatingly terrible
jumping puzzle just indescribably bad in
its fundamental construction riddled
with all manner of collision problems
and very much coming off as a
half-hearted idea that was implemented
improvisationally and never actually
tested let alone revised with the reward
being a broken scavenger token Z
fighting textures and a bad view of the
party
right is that it was that it
after a Long Day's virtual lawyering
it's only natural that you'll want to
take a load off and we would recommend
none other than nft Worlds nft world
cities Comedy Club it's always bugged me
when I go into a comedy club and I'm not
immediately met with comedy it's false
advertising but with the power of the
metaverse and a 120 000 Grant from the
decentraland Dow the nft world cities
Comedy Club obtained an infinite source
of Comedy uh we hope to have some
content from decentral Comedy soon and
we have also sourced content from a an
AI tool called chat GPT which uh
um provides some jokes for us to show
here
it's not all comedy and incompetence and
insincerity though occasionally you'll
stumble across a single plot that's just
a simple Shrine to a loved one taken
away from this world too young and oh
hey it's another modern Mario house one
of the most consistently popular
locations in decentraland popular enough
to Warrant a functionally permanent spot
on the Genesis Plaza hot locations board
is the wondermind meteor Mining and
crafting game now something to stress
here is that this is within the context
of decentraland a success story there
are people who interface with
decentraland solely as the medium by
which they access wondermind even just
looking at the map it is one of the few
consistently occupied places where you
can find other players in any reasonable
number and it is an idle clicking game
that is so sluggish in its Pace that it
barely qualifies as a Skinner box
meteors fall and you click on them and
then you wait the sole value Prospect is
that at the end of the process you might
be able to craft an nft where terrible
that you can then sell to someone else
so like I was saying if you want to see
what this is worth we can go over to the
marketplace and search steampunk hat and
as you can see it's worth 240
2499 Mana the value of Mana today it's
over a dollar
so with such big money on the line of
course the game is botted to Helen Back
with idlers and auto clickers
decentraland doesn't log users out after
a set time spent idle and the meteors
fall in predictable locations so it's
pretty easy to automate but even barring
that level of complexity it's trivial to
just leave a tab idle and collect the
periodic rewards wondermind is also
immediately adjacent to one of the
oldest games in decentraland Dragon Rush
which is featured prominently in Genesis
Plaza immediately we can spot a problem
with the real estate model of the
internet this relatively modest game has
an absolutely massive footprint and
necessitates a towering retaining wall
to back its terrain from a standpoint of
architecture it's an immensely hostile
block a massive impassable barrier to
both sight lines and traffic it turns
out that having every individual app and
website take up scarespace in an
adversarial relationship is
bad
all right so walk on to the Dragon's
Back press F to Flap wings and fly go
through the gates and land on the
landing pad to finish the race
now maybe this is just unfair after all
I did say the Dragon Rush is one of the
oldest games in decentraland let's do
some due diligence and find something
more mature more refined something with
a budget behind it
foreign
[Music]
the ultimate role-playing game that will
challenge you to Farm Craft and fight
your way to the top those looking for a
little more action to their decentral
end experience need look no further than
ice Masters an incredible fully playable
role-playing game built within the meta
vs trusty framework within its sizeable
location Gamers can undertake quests
battle enemies collect resources and
craft and game items all in addition to
ridding the realm of the terrible
poultry Scourge Dice Masters development
and expansion show The Following tier VI
up to 240 000 USD 6 months vesting one
month Cliff Grant in the gaming category
be approved yes wins with 93 percent
well okay that's quite a pitch and you
know what let's treat this seriously
like let's treat this like it were a
Kickstarter or steam Early Access pitch
000 is modest but realistic and watching
the trailer it's all very achievable
especially since the buildings are just
lifted from World of Warcraft but like
the features are very straightforward
and the trailer even evokes the central
land style this is eminently realizable
low rent sure devoid of original ideas
also true doable absolutely this is it
right this is the moment decentraland
has been waiting for this is the
realization of all their promises this
isn't just a thing in decentraland it's
decentraland as a platform as the
infrastructure invisible beneath an
otherwise independent game experience
they even bothered to include the
coordinates in the trailer like they
actually want you to go there
[Music]
foreign
it's just
it's the same story over and over again
everywhere you go in decentraland it's
all the same stuff no amount of remixing
can overcome the underlying flaws of the
base layer decentraland wants to be the
invisible Tech behind the scenes but it
can't because it also wants to be a real
virtual world and the one goal imposes
endless creative and Technical decisions
on to the other you can't really get
anything better out of the system
foreign
the metagamma mall is a construction of
special note because its existence was
made possible by a grant of 220 000 US
dollars from the decentraland Dao the
organization that operates in theory as
the government of the decentraland world
the pitch was a gamified mall and I will
let their own pitch package speak for
itself on some key details
game plus Mall equals communal
real Vitality of them all the p2e
model can incentivize users to play and
earn the first comprehensive traffic
Road system into Central and highly
compatible with customer shopping habits
and super dodrio game The Meta gaming
nail is an avant-garde Endeavor to blur
the boundaries between game and shock
activity the game lives in the mall the
mall needs the game
need to check the price of the one that
one claimed by a single clue the actual
product is a track that you walk along
to collect coins that can be traded for
wearables while a bad techno DJ repeats
the instructions on an endless loop
because space is so tight even for large
plots like this the track consists
mostly of really obnoxious Spirals and
the places infested with Bots that idle
on the exact same spot until the timer
resets and they can collect more coins
it would seem that while two hundred and
twenty thousand dollars can get you a
lot of stuff it can't get you an
experience worth doing with your own
human hands the actual rules of super
dogeario are oblique and the DJ's
instructions don't actually help
welcome to melamine melamine is a
metaverse game event that will begin
from 18th November and many gaming more
descending one melamine is a metaverse
game even that will be guess it's called
metamine now as for the mall component I
don't even know what to say the space is
so cluttered with the extreme cyberspace
aesthetic that it's barely even legible
as a mall and the whole notion is Keel
hauled by the fact that this is a
miserable interface for actually buying
things which is the actual purpose of a
mall the result an empty shopping
experience plagued with Bots isn't just
a dead mall it's an undead Mall
stuttering along in a parody of life now
they did seek a new Grant in late 2022
asking for an additional 60 000 USD to
expand and Revitalize them all
unfortunately the proposal was rejected
three million to 9 million with 7.8
million of the no votes coming from two
people sorry metagamama Mall better luck
next time the decentraland report is one
of the most fascinating elements of
decentraland and it breaks my heart that
we can't give it the time it truly
deserves they style themselves as the
first ever decentralized News Network
reporting on the latest breaking news of
the metaverse between grants and private
funding it has received over 250 000 USD
a quarter million dollars of investment
it is an organization operated by Kevin
Clark better known by his handle Kevin
on Earth 999 will let him explain what
it means
decentralized news networks give the
public the power to control event
coverage reporters and how the network
will evolve over time tokens are
distributed to the public based on
participation and can be used to
purchase event coverage ad space and
vote on key decisions such as the
addition or removal of actual news
reporters just to stress this to
highlight it and make sure that you're
aware this is not us catastrophizing or
editorializing the ability for the crowd
to fire reporters is an explicit it
feature imagine if you could use a token
to vote off a reporter from the news you
can buy the ability to fire a reporter
and that's deliberate because it gives
the token resale value which
incentivizes participation the editorial
agenda of the decentraland report is not
just nominally available for purchase it
is proudly available for purchase the
decentraland report is a news outlet
that hates journalism it takes the very
messy subject of journalistic
Independence the way that journalism
often functions as willing collaborators
with systemic power and the reasons why
we should be legitimately skeptical
alert and literate in how we intake
media and uses that to advocate for a
radical populism masquerading as
neutrality the logic is that
institutions are inherently biased
therefore less institution means less
bias and no institution means no bias
their trust model is explicitly rooted
in their income competence Kevin's
rhetoric is part and parcel with the
conspiratorial thinking that leads
people to trust misinformation they
found on Facebook specifically because
they found it on a page that gets
flagged by Facebook as misinformation it
shares a table with the belief that
reporters exist to deceive the public
and so the only journalism you can trust
comes from those who hate journalism
with this decentralized approach to news
the public can take control of global
narratives focus on fact-based reporting
versus bias based reporting which is
focused more on getting views than
telling the truth Kevin's vision for the
news is downright dystopian it's a
killer writing prompt if you're in need
of ideas so what's the product you want
to see some journalism so unprofessional
that it would make even the writers at
the defiant cringe
any giveaways yeah for sure man if you
hang around I'll definitely do a
giveaway man
[Music]
so we just hop on in right here to Dice
Masters highly encourage you guys come
on through I just want to show support
to Dice Masters you know and then we'll
kind of move it into the auction phase
uh with um you know hopping from gallery
to gallery
that is that sounds like like a great
time as recommended by shiny upon the
passing of this grant we agree to pay
back 10 of our monthly Revenue to the
doubt in perpetuity until the grant
amount is paid back to the Dow that's
amazing that to me is
Epic
it's just twitch streams
[Music]
that's what the [__] metaverse was
missing Meadow
that is very true holy [__] that is very
freaking true
wow
that was Big Dave
says Big Dave is talking listen the [__]
up wow
that was wow
wow
that was sound check you gotta be
kidding me
that was freaking sound check you gotta
be kidding me I know I know right it's
pretty disappointing that after all that
talk about the philosophy of Journalism
this ship runs the ground over the fact
that nothing remotely worth reporting
happens in decentraland in the first
place so the risk of journalistic
malpractice is functionally zero despite
the lofty Ambitions of the network these
guys are ultimately harmless they're
just small streamers cosplaying as
reporters while hanging out with their
handful of regulars talking about the
video game they like to play that said
there is still a story here they still
raised a quarter million dollars right
did that at least pay someone well no
reporters aren't paid as such they get
paid in the report token and they get a
cut of the organization's monthly
revenue on expand a crypto meets Twitter
meets patreon platform at the time of
writing that's around 120 bucks total
expand takes a 10 cut there's another 10
cut for their Grant repayment a phrase
that shouldn't exist and then the
remainder is split nine ways there's the
possibility of one-time donations on top
of that which get cut the same way but
on average the individual reporters are
looking at about 10 bucks a month this
isn't a great deal especially since the
streamers sorry
reporters need to provide their own
equipment so it's no surprise that Kevin
has failed to dry in any Pulitzer Prize
winners who he's ended up with is an
ensemble of decentraland users who just
want to grow their stream by associating
with an org they're all broadcasting
from their personal twitch streams what
they get from the org is The dclr
Branding which you know it doesn't draw
in the crowds every single stream we
caught had extremely low viewership
almost always fewer than 10 viewers
often under five Kevin's personal and
dclr branded YouTube channels don't fare
any better a video is a success if it
breaks 100 views so where on Kevin on
Earth did the money go okay
the reporters only get paid from the
expand pot dclr doesn't buy them lights
or webcams the only thing left to even
spend it on
is decentraland itself
[Music]
the decentraland report is the perfect
Showcase of web 3's ability to cause
money to just evaporate the build is
called the metaflower which is a
reference to an nft of a super yacht
from other medivers candidate the
sandbox that sold know what doesn't
matter using allegedly very expensive
Tech the flower is intended to develop
and Bloom as the number of subscribers
on the expand page grows of course we
need to take Kevin's word on that
because the count is currently 22
followers towards the goal of ten
thousand so the building has remained in
its initial form
what we're left with is this we've got
walls laced with Kevin's prized nfts two
platforms that I am assured are the
studios where presenters are intended to
stand the decision room where the dclr
Dao members will meet once the Dow gets
some and then we have the butthole
tunnel that takes us to an alien in a
rice paddy hat who tells us that we need
to save the decentraland report by
gathering news juice and it turns out
that news juice means please follow
Kevin and Pals on Twitter wait
Kevin's in here twice
strangely there is no news in the DCL
rhqq what they do give you is a link to
an entirely different 3D web application
called on Cyber so you're sitting there
computer frying from running
decentraland and if you want to see some
news at the metaverse news building
Kevin wants you to open up another 3D
site that loads up two dozen YouTube
videos at once and then crashes Firefox
entirely it's absurd needless to say the
decentraland build contributes extremely
little to the utility of running a News
Network we don't know precisely how much
this whole thing cost Beyond about
thirty five thousand dollars for the
land but given that the 127 000 in
Grants are reasonably well accounted for
it would seem that after the boring
stuff like building the website and
twitch assets this as a whole represents
Kevin's 126 thousand dollars
so let's focus on those grants Kevin
received four grants from the
decentraland Dow two were to hire an
editor for dclr both paid the editor 50
per edit
in Mana then there was a five thousand
dollar Grant in September of 2021 to
create unique in-game jackets for
reporters as a milestone reward for six
months work and then there was the big
one a 120 000 U.S Grant and stable coins
to build the back end for dclr's reward
System since decentralized news is all
about rewarding participation including
viewership you need to build that system
pretty much the same Tech that handles
twitch drops to service a community of
like 30 people the decentralized
philosophy of the project demands this
type of massive inefficient system
exists as a starting point you can't
expand into these Solutions naturally so
Kevin spent 35 000 on land potentially
91 000 on the studio build five thousand
on jackets and 120 000 on this reward
system and then went back to the grant
program looking for another 240 000 32
of which was allotted to reporter
equipment and included salaries for a
marketing director content manager
graphic designer and so on in what would
seem to have been the only Lucid moment
in the fever dream of the grant scheme
Kevin was told no two more reduced
proposals have also been rejected
you know what we haven't talked about in
a while
chocolate I mean sure lint has their
metaverse but surely chocolate giant
Hershey wouldn't be left behind well if
you've got a craving you're in luck just
a hop skip and a jump from the Sugar
Club you can experience Hershey verse
the official metaverse holiday home of
Hershey chocolates of India and the
Philippines sure this plot may look
microscopic but boy howdy is there a lot
to do for one you can talk to the
shopkeepers inside and they'll send you
a link to Amazon but there's also
gamification there's a quest it's time
for a treasure hunt just hop up here and
bounce over here and click on this and
ride the elevator and click on the
camera and you can get your very own
official Hershey versus wearable an nft
on the frequently exploited polygon
blockchain it would appear that this hat
has been claimed generously about 500
times
but once you claim your extremely ugly
hat you get one last quest to extend
your time in the Hershey verse you see
the treasure chest needs opening and the
keys won't find themselves so you just
talk to the shopkeepers and pick up the
keys off the ground and click the thing
and uh you gain the ability to fly and
by fly I mean that if you double jump an
invisible platform spawns under you and
lifts you up to a predetermined height
where you can jump to one of the clouds
and take control of the chocolate Cannon
which may or may not work
Brands love the metaverse or at least
that's the story Samsung Nissan
vitaphone Snapple Citibank pedigree
Hershey Mountain Dew Trident Sour Patch
Kids Atari Miller Lite JP Morgan
everyone's getting in on the metaverse
now what that means is
um
extremely flexible we've already dipped
into Hershey verse but what else is out
there it's just
it's weird man Atari has probably the
best looking location of any of these
but it still principally consists of a
large faux social Space full of
furniture that you can't interact with
wait have I even mentioned that yet yeah
you can't sit on chairs in decentraland
the whole goddamn world is built of
nothing but hangout spots and you can't
even role play sitting around a table
unless you buy the user created sit
emote from the marketplace otherwise in
the Atari stronghold you have a slate of
links that I'll take you out of
decentraland and a couple wearables that
are no longer available the only thing
to actually do here is play one of the
four variants of breakout and feel the
gnawing cold reality seep into you as
you realize the decentraland is such a
Monumental failure as a platform for
socialization for Commerce and for
gaming that it can't even handle
properly emulating Breakout a game from
1976 that you can play on goddamn Google
images Steve Wozniak built breakout 50
years ago to run on 44 TTL chips and a
ham sandwich and that's still somehow
two demanding a gaming experience for
decentraland
the Onyx Lounge by JPMorgan Chase built
in March 2022 and described by Fortune
as a bet on a metaverse future that
could be worth trillions was originally
staffed only by a Wandering Tiger but
has since been replaced with a cramped
reading Lounge the DCL branch of HSBC is
a unique kind of awful with this deeply
unsettling robot receptionist and stairs
with no collision with the only problem
being that it's not clear if this is an
official HSBC project or not since
impersonation is Trivial and even the
official builds are glitchy and weird
because it's decentraland everything is
glitchy and weird particularly though as
you go through a lot of these you start
to notice a few Trends first is a
subject that we'll talk about at length
later which is the discussion of these
Ventures rarely feature anything
meaningful they don't tend to tell you
how to actually find the location and
tend to downplay the product itself
typically limiting visuals to a wide
screenshot of an exterior if anything at
all Fortune didn't even bother to
mention the Tiger It's really more about
the headline than the actual space
second is a trend of dispersion it's not
Hershey's that's in the metaverse it's
Hershey's India and Philippines it's
Nissan Italy it's Vodafone turkey third
is a trend towards the temporary well
the Atari metaverse headquarters is
still standing and the Onyx Lounge by JP
Morgan Chase still sort of technically
exists most of these aren't actually
Brands moving to the metaverse they're
just promotional campaigns the Snapple
stronghold Miller Lite metal light bar
and Hershey verse are already gone and
look we've heard there aren't um a lot
of people inside the metaverse yet but
marketers say it's going to be a very
big deal the metaversity of stacom came
and went in about two months the Trident
Vibe X Sour Patch Kids chew The Vibes
dance party has been replaced by an
office for Moses worldwide the Ad Agency
that built it while a few corporations
jumped in early and actually bought land
that ship has seemingly already sailed
and now the impetus for this isn't
originating with the brands but with the
digital ad agencies that they hire who
then toss in a decentraland activation
as part of the package a way to recoup
some value from the land that the Ad
Agency bought fourth is that they just
overwhelmingly suck and need to
constantly direct users out of
decentraland in order to accomplish
anything the Nissan experience will let
you book a test drive in Italy if you
click a link to open their existing
website the Atari store opens atari's
actual store the pedigree fosterverse
lets land holders create a metaverse
duplicate of a real dog in a partnered
shelter in need of a forever home the
metaverse dog serves as a digital
billboard leading to the dog's adopt a
pet page of the three dogs the platform
list at the time of writing all three
have long since been adopted out but
their listings remain because the
incentive for land holders to
participate is to get a pedigree branded
dog on their parcel so the metaverse
dogs are doomed to beg for adoption for
all eternity so what does that all mean
well the obvious but speculative
narrative is that ad agencies that have
a stake in the success of the metaverse
are approaching brands in smaller
markets and pitching them on a version
of the future and dazzling them with
some cooked numbers they point to
articles in real Outlets like Fortune
with titles referencing a trillion
dollar future and like in the face of
that can you even afford the possibility
of being wrong it's the lamest version
of Pascal's wager back on the Genesis
Plaza spawn platform we've got these
pillars that I've shown but not really
talked about yet these are decentralized
solution to discoverability in their
metaverse or well at least one of their
attempted Solutions as already mentioned
the classics pillar includes Dragon rash
in the coveted bottom spot where you can
actually interact without needing to
crank the camera or use the awkward
skill geomorphic buttons on the right
hand side though is the crowds pillar
and for the last year one location has
dominated that bottom slot ice poker the
stronghold which routinely boasts over
100 attendees often pushing 200. now
that number is middling in isolation but
by the standards of decentraland where
12 qualifies as a crowd it's pretty
meaningful of course a ton of those
attendees are idle at the default spawn
location but let's not ruin the fun
[Music]
as for the legality of this well the
opinion of decentral games
singapore-based lawyers is that it's not
gambling under relevant statutes thus
they don't need a gaming license to
operate the important thing here is that
the only thing in decentraland that
seems to be actually successful is
outright just a casino and regardless of
the sentiments of jock Law LLC the
community seems to be taking it for what
it clearly is
so as you can see I've earned 2.98 uh
from playing and honestly I've only been
gambling oh playing the casino for a
couple of days the odd thing is that
it's seemingly only the poker tables at
that like really it's just this one
specific Casino there's a whole bunch of
different casinos around the gambling
Zone basically all of them owned by
decenture games under the ice brand but
the stronghold is the only one anyone's
ever in
turns out that's because they already
ran into legal problems you used to be
able to gamble on the slots at tomanoia
with your cryptocurrency directly but
between glitchy Behavior they would eat
transactions High service fees long wait
times to resolve bets and most
critically some pointed letters from
various regulatory bodies the stronghold
is the only location that supports the
current brown bag policy and it only has
poker all the others have been converted
to free play you can still go over to
the aquarium and play Blackjack but you
will do so alone these people are not
here to play they are here to gamble
when discussing decentraland it's hard
to overlook the subject of its abysmal
user base indeed the biggest story to
come out of decentraland in 2022 was
drama over dcl's metrics in October 2022
crypto Outlet coindesk reported on
Dapper Radar's data that claimed
decentraland had as few as 38 daily
active users decentraland fired back in
a blog post scrutinizing the data
calling it misinformation and pushing
their own value of 8 000. this back and
forth continued with coindesk releasing
the final word on the subject in January
2023 with their research suggesting an
active daily user base of 810. now it's
tempting to fall into this Whirlpool as
apparently coindesk did for three months
and litigate the definition of a user
but let's head this off at the pass
weather decentraland has daily activity
of 40 users 800 users or 8 000 users is
irrelevant in their business these are
all all the same number emotionally it
feels like a significant difference but
let's give some context to these numbers
at 810 users it's competing with Lord of
the Rings online and it has a fraction
of the users a phishing planet which
like
its fishing Planet the most generous
numbers for decentraland put it in
competition with Star Wars the Old
Republic all of these values are just
steam users it doesn't include the users
who access the games directly through
their dedicated launchers or on other
platforms so these numbers are
inherently conservative now despite
having these varying player counts these
games all have fundamentally the same
business model they are operating a
micro MMO if you ever wonder how dead
MMOs survive it's by running tight ships
these teams often small inherit a
product that was hugely expensive to
produce 5 10 15 years ago and they are
tasked with maintaining it in order to
support a small but loyal user base it
is possible for Runes of Magic to be
profitable off the back of a single
digit number of whales people who just
really like Runes of Magic the same is
true for Fiesta Online or lotro so it
doesn't matter what decentraland's true
daily user count looks like because any
number they've ever pushed falls into
the same band of long long dead MMO the
fact that decentraland has a similar
user base to DC Universe Online is the
red flag that most people notice first
Daybreak a game company is a game
developer that currently owns and
maintains numerous old MMOs including
EverQuest DC Universe online and Lord of
the Rings Online this is a tough
business and in December of 2020
Daybreak was acquired by Enad Global 7
in an agreement valued at 300 million
dollars so this company that owns and
maintains all these MMOs that are all
individually comparable to
decentraland's user base is meant to be
worth a fraction of decentraland and
this is the story behind the company
worth nearly 10 billion dollars at the
market Peak it's been said numerous
times before but it shouldn't be left on
said here decentraland's purported value
based on the market cap of its
cryptocurrency is completely
disconnected from reality decentraland's
product is clearly trash as a video game
it struggles to set itself apart from
Inferno an MMO that advertises itself as
an underdog off of the back of its
three-man Dev team so decentraland goes
all in on the speculation on narrative
its value has nothing to do with what
the central land is today but what it
will be and what it did do when you
weren't watching
because the metaverse in its more mature
form will be a lot more advanced than
this and be a lot more sophisticated
than this but this really is how it
starts this is the beginning of it and
you know this is going to be the shape
of things for the next 20 30 years I
genuinely believe that the way that
crypto users talk about decentraland is
so dissociated from what you yourself
witness that it seems like they're
talking about an entirely different
thing like is this it is this the
billion dollar virtual world surely I
must be missing something I'm sorry you
don't like to make money here in the
network but uh like so much of web3
decentraland has weaponized its
speculative element since they are the
future the product as it exists now
borders on irrelevant the proposed
inevitability of the metaverse is their
greatest asset because they don't even
need to try this is the everything proof
shield that decentraland users have
created to guard from criticism
decentraland and all its contents is
forever a prototype always just an
indication of what the future will bring
being bad is not a flaw in the crypto
space just look at the red ape family
they're visibly incompetent and they
still made it to three episodes even if
the Creator is too much of a coward to
post the third publicly every successful
crypto project is bad but with enough
legitimacy you can mask that fact this
generates extremely funny scenarios like
crypto shill Robin from the defiant
stumbling through decentraland's Barren
Wasteland while trying to invent reasons
why what he's looking at isn't plainly
obviously ass and I often say that the
metaverse is
it's a world that rotates around you
and this is what I mean the world
literally does rotate around you this is
It's a universe where you are always at
the center so that is the whole kind of
mindset change that you have to get when
you talk about the metaverse it's the
central land users understand this need
for legitimacy intuitively and so it
becomes what they crave above all else
this is why they value brand Activation
so highly no matter the circumstances
being able to put Vodafone on their
world map or pedigree in their events
tab spins the narrative that real
companies are here in decentraland even
embarrassing brand activations are
defended because they're just dipping
their toes in this is just at the
beginning decentraland users seek to
encourage brand activations and events
through pathetic pandering they'll smile
through gritted teeth as they insist
that the Hershey experience really is
interesting and successful by
performatively engaging with events and
brand activations users seek to create
the illusion that these events are
successful in the hopes of drawing in
the next sucker what's cooking good
looking people we're into Central and
we're in Hershey verse can you believe
that Hershey's bro Hershey however you
say Hershey I'm pretty sure it was
Hershey's the [__] Mandela bro who would
have thought Hershey was gonna make a
little plot on the central land you know
before you know you're gonna see other
candy companies you know there's already
beverage companies they're already
alcohol companies there's [__] Yahoo
Amazon is already in here and Hershey is
the next big one to get into this [__]
this principle scales up from the
pedigree Foster verse all the way up to
the Marquee events of the platform the
metaverse music festival which in its
most recent outing was tossed around as
having featured performances from Bjork
Ozzy Osbourne and Motorhead consisted
almost entirely of pre-recorded messages
from the musicians followed by just
playing a couple music videos
with you
with you and it's great to be here into
Central land I hope you're all having a
good time today my name is Dave Mustaine
from Megadeth and today I'll be playing
a few of my favorite tracks let me know
what you think about this one
[Music]
I criticized fortnite for being overly
poetic with its definition of a live
marshmallow concert and this is just
this is just so much worse the metaverse
Fashion Week as the name implies was a
week-long Fashion Event held in
decentraland in March of 2022 scheduled
to run just after the Milan Fashion Week
the event was organized by the
decentraland foundation the developers
of decentraland it was the involvement
of the foundation that saw the metaverse
Fashion Week get some real attention and
media coverage a number of Lifestyle
fashion and Tech journalists were sent
in to cover the event for whom many were
experiencing the metaverse for the first
time the event was billed as an
opportunity to see the next major
innovation in the fashion industry a new
way for fashion to be designed bought
and sold it would be the melding of
fashion and art finally art and fashion
together at last the word fijidal got
thrown around a lot to refer to the
simultaneous purchasing of a digital
invisible good like you buy a digital
hat in decentraland and a real hat turns
up in the mail not to get distracted but
World of Warcraft did this exact
promotion in 2010. this plush wind rider
Cub came with an in-game pet it's not a
new thing but of course they don't frame
it that way instead you're buying a
single hat with two simultaneous planes
of existence it's not a bundle of two
products it's the same hat in two
different forms there are dozens of tech
startups eager to composite clothing
over photo or video and label it as the
future of self-expression the so-called
screenware is at best an Artful
Photoshop job and at worst essentially
just a tick tock or Zoom filter well
there are different Avenues so the first
thing is you could wear it on your real
self through an AR filter
so that's number one and that's the part
where technology is still you know work
in progress it's going to get better and
better we know it so I think as we
regular people start transitioning more
and more into the virtual world spending
more time in Virtual environments and
that that very a bit on physical and
digital starts blurring more and more
and we will start consuming you know
digital fashion digital sneakers digital
makeup digital jewelry this was the
rhetoric that defined the metaverse
Fashion Week so our ragtag Ensemble of
journalists and creators were sent in to
report on the future of reality and
fashion how did it go
do you really need to be told at this
point
what the [__] did I just watch after a
pre-show trial session spent exploring
decentraland's luxury fashion district
maybe it was too early but the only
fashion space I teleported to was an
empty DKNY store while there were plenty
of fashion shows very few were
successful because the overall
experience fell flat perhaps expectedly
many were able to capture the magic of a
physical show where attendees are fully
immersed and emotionally invested in the
Brand's collection they gamified
aesthetic in central land took away from
the fantasy and craftsmanship of luxury
fashion and simply put the Avatar models
weren't as inspiring
foreign
[Music]
I don't know how I feel about it I
literally canceled everything including
my workout to watch this show and there
was just very little documenting of the
event in general this is due to a
combination of disinterest but also a
deliberate effort not to showcase the
embarrassing product even the brands
involved in the show downplayed the
decentraland part of their decentraland
show the shows didn't look the way the
brands expected they would as
Publications on the social networks made
clear this is because Brands posted the
best photos from the show and not the
reality of pixelated avatars and simple
looks likewise musicians who performed
at the music festival didn't exactly
rush to show off the event either so
footage of any of these theoretically
big events is shockingly sparse this
isn't some Grand conspiracy it's just
dozens of individuals independently
reaching the same conclusion the product
sucks and it'd be a bad idea to show it
this is true for both DCL users but also
the Gen journalists covering it
decentraland looks so unprofessional
that coverage of decentraland looks
unprofessional by extension and this
actually looks it looks sort of like me
I like it so much I'm going to dance for
you this is my happy dance we do have a
whiskey Distillery you've been holding
out
oh this is cool here we can walk around
and actually see The Distillery from
inside I enjoy your virtual Distillery
not so much your virtual bourbon so
cheers Gigi cheers to that
I I mean so here's the thing I
is it for us I don't know but there are
hundreds of thousands of people who
already live yeah diverse do you exist
in the metaverse who are buying things
this creates an environment where the
metaverse Fashion Week was a thing
talked about in the abstract it was a
thing that did happen but the reality is
slowly eroded away most people who
learned about the event didn't see the
product they only heard the narrative
and that narrative went a little
something like this the wearables were
supposed to be available immediately
after the runway event at a nearby
pop-up shop and for free a rarity
considering Fashions rushed to
capitalize on crypto clothing
for some reason a couple of hours after
it ended they weren't displayed yet
inside the Paisley patterned store a
good reason to come back
this journalist witnessed a broken
feature they experienced a bug rather
than reporting critically on the failure
of a key feature of the event the
article pulls its punch in the last line
through the language of puff journalism
out of context it reads almost like
satire but if you read enough coverage
of decentraland this becomes a very real
Trend last of all I can definitely see
this event evolving into something much
more engaging there are communities of
people who are replicating in various
metaverse outposts behaviors that people
or people dressed as elves have long
cultivated in reality and fashion is one
of those behaviors so we're all just
going to need a better graphics card how
however mvfw did provide a glimpse into
possibilities for how Brands can build
their narratives in the metaverse
offering immersive experiences and
innovative ways to expand offerings
beyond the physical once VR glasses are
integrated the experience is going to be
on a whole other level and in the
absence of any voices to the contrary
that becomes The Narrative of the
metaverse Fashion Week it had some
technical issues reviews were mixed but
it was a proof of concept that left
journalists feeling certain that the
concept has a future and through that
lens that allows those involved to say
with a straight face that the event was
a success yeah it was a fantastic four
days as a proof point of what is to come
this is the early evolution of
decentralized commas on the whole
journalists are seemingly overwhelmed by
The Tempest of claims and ideas
surrounding the metaverse we can
appreciate why this is the case a lot of
this is vague either on purpose or on
accident it is not the job of the
writers at women's wear daily to crack
crypto wide open it's all too big too
out of scope they're convinced that they
just don't get it so they defer to the
explanations and narratives given to
them by people trying to sell something
I mean so here's the thing I I
Eric ravenscraft has discussed this
phenomenon with a specific eye towards
journalists in Outlets like the New York
Times uncritically parroting the
vocabulary of real estate for the
digital groundbreaking of metaverse
headquarters that in many cases don't
even actually exist this goes all the
way back to the first major coverage
given to decentraland a BBC story in
2018 in response to the initial land
auction in decentraland users can build
whatever they can imagine on plots of
virtual land
but the creators are giving BBC trending
a sneak peek of what the city will look
like when it launches what's important
to remember here is that the
decentraland we're seeing wouldn't exist
for another two years the actual product
in 2018 looked like this so by its very
nature there is nothing really to show
and it means we get these lovely little
artifacts from the past
right whoa okay I've seen to be having
some sort of dance floor I can hear
music it's very colorful
so it seems to be like a zombie
just out in the distance oh gosh he's
coming right at me it'll be pretty much
exactly the same as Facebook except
you'll be able to hear and see each
other
um be it in VR so a bit more of a real
experience as long as we've got the
internet stick our headsets on and we'll
be able to have friends come around my
house into Central end or I can go to
their house for a virtual cup of tea how
high would the price have to get for you
to sell that land yeah I'm not selling
it until it's worth at least 10 million
10 million yeah he sold for 980 a year
later a million dollars but it doesn't
exist it does here and it will do in
about a year I believe the spine of this
story is built not on what decentraland
did or was doing but what it will do all
of the features that will be implemented
and benchmarks it will hit journalists
and vloggers who very understandably
don't know the Deep lore of
decentralized development still mention
VR is a thing that just hasn't been
implemented yet despite the feature
being scrapped once VR glasses are
integrated the experience is going to be
on a whole other level the central land
craves legitimacy but it can subsist on
crumbs it is a speculative real estate
scheme which is rapidly approaching the
Nigerian prince level of self-selection
that means that for its purposes all it
needs is for people to discuss it and
for the conversation to feature the
defenses we've been discussing it's just
a prototype it will improve the
metaverse
is inevitable because this reporting
loads the basis for investment advice
like this to sound believable land is
hitting all-time highs for value and
people are asking like you know Can
people really afford to buy these plots
for a lot yes because there's going to
be a large commercial and business
entities that can make a lot more than
what they're going to pay for this land
they know it that has long-term
ramifications in the industry so it's a
great investment if you took Kevin's
advice at the time you'd be in the red
less than two weeks later have lost half
your investment two months later and be
down 80 to 90 percent today that is the
danger posed by nonchalant coverage of
decentraland boosting The Narrative that
major brands and mass adoption are right
around the corner there's no such thing
as bad publicity for decentraland it
continues to obsess through performative
hype and deception but decentraland
needs to be recognized for what it is
and we can't give it the easy way out
decentraland is not and has never been a
VR experience you cannot order a pizza
in decentraland decentraland is not the
future it has never and will never be
worth a billion dollars
so at this point I think it's plain to
see that the product of decentraland is
at best bad but decentraland users are
battle hardened on this point they've
had years of Defending against this
claim many DCL users will concede that
sure the product itself is janky but
obviously it's just a prototype the real
appeal of decentraland what sets it
apart from its competition is its system
of governance so Central land was built
and is maintained by the foundation the
actual developers behind the product
Malik and ordano always intended for the
foundation to go hands off simply
becoming the underlying Machinery of the
world akin to the invisibility of a web
host as part of this invisibility they
wanted users to handle as many elements
of development and maintenance as
possible this is characterized through
the language of ownership decentraland
is owned by its users so naturally the
users have direct control over the price
product this is further obfuscated
through the language of decentraland as
a reified space which is to say
decentraland users present themselves as
akin to the government of a virtual
world enacting policies in a democratic
fashion they do this through the
decentraland Dao because the
decentralandau addresses itself in the
language of governance and law it's
tempting to engage with them on that
level and take the Dao seriously we
tried to give them a fair go but we
found ourselves repeating the mistakes
of the journalists we just criticized to
contrast them against Real governments
implies that the comparison is warranted
and humor is the notion that these are
adults attempting to revolutionize the
concept of governance so let's adjust
expectations and lead with the soul of
the Dao upon revisiting the Dao's
governance site for this project the
first thing that caught our eye was this
a proposal to fire a Committee Member
for abuse of power and bias and let me
tell you the contents of this would be
right at home on something awful Circa 2
2008 a guy got banned on Discord and got
so upset that he wrote a thousand word
essay on a sock puppet about why the
moderator should be fired for abusing
their Authority because when asked the
moderator kinda said he was a pluralist
and pluralists hate the individual and
on and on it goes the proposal was
rejected but it was rejected as an
invalid question because the team
manager of the Dow facilitation Squad
does not count as a member of the Dow
committee and thus a complaint would
need to be made to the grant support
Squad who would then need to recommend a
proposal to revoke the grant funding the
Dow facilitation Squad thus firing
matimio indirectly then there's Kevin's
failed Grant proposal where multiple
people rejected the proposal at least in
part because Kevin blocked them on
Twitter when you block someone on
Twitter this is where they end up this
is a group of people that sees the Sugar
Club the empty bar next to Hershey's
requesting 60 000 US dollars to fund its
operating costs and they're like yeah
yeah that seems reasonable when they
hold elections candidates are asked
questions like what are each candidate's
stance on bringing physical world
ideologies into our decentralized world
you know government structures democracy
communism whatever in that example the
candidates universally accepted the idea
that DCL was apolitical and they would
support politics being patched into
decentraland but only if it achieved
majority support in an official vote
this is like a grand experiment however
there's there's a lot at stake so I
think any ideology that we're
considering bringing in it would be uh
best handled on uh you know on a side
project my dudes the ideology is coming
from inside the house their philosophy
of governance minimizes individual
Authority and decision making but they
pass full legislation that gives
committee members absolute discretion
with no appeals process the decentraland
Dao is no less of a failure than the
Hershey's experience or decentially
we're just changing gears from Bad video
games to bureaucratic incompetence you
can't really understand the Dao until
you wrap your head around just how
inequitable the voting situation is Dows
often make use of weighted voting
schemes the main purpose of this is to
acknowledge a user stake in the project
the logic being that those with the most
invested have the most at stake in the
Dow though the details can vary between
Dao's decentraland scheme is
refreshingly straightforward votes are
weighted based on the sum of
decentraland tokens in the attached
wallet one Mana is worth one point of
vote power it's just wealth the more
money you have the more your vote counts
one to one naturally this leads to those
with wealth shutting down any proposal
that bothers them for instance let's
look at this proposal should we address
voting power distribution in the Dow in
The Proposal a Dao Committee Member
pointed out the obvious issues of the
system and the results turned out like
this
163 votes 4 45 against that is 78
support in terms of real votes though
we'll get to that but once voting power
was accounted for the margin inverted to
73 percent against and then even within
that of the 5.18 million VP against the
proposal 4 million came from a single
wallet four wallets make up almost all
of the votes against the proposal
99.7 of the VP in the 73 percent
majority The Next Step would naturally
be to play with these figures versus the
real votes you know two percent of
Voters accounted for 73 percent of the
VP but the issue there is that even
though this weighted system allegedly
exists to combat Bots users still use
Bots for the Optics when you actually
look at the votes 128 of the 200 nine
votes were from accounts with zero VP
these were accounts with literally no
influence on the vote eighty percent of
those dummy votes were for yes 19 of
these accounts only had a single VP and
then a bunch had two both equally
capable of being sock puppets but
whether guest 60fd is a real user or not
is irrelevant because one wallet lapped
to the competition one wallet told the
Dow to go just itself just just really
just
and the Dow politely complied
these whales are often burner accounts
who are not available for negotiation
their decrees are silent yet drown out
all other voices but there is still an
urge to pretend like negotiation is a
possibility but we still got it denied
although we met the threshold of
approval in the final hours we did get
uh three votes which came in to deny and
sort of made us step back and say we
need to reevaluate how we're bringing
this forward because ultimately even
reaching the VP threshold of approval by
the community it seems like the whales
still felt like something else needed to
be addressed outside of the other
feedback which we had Kevin is clearly
upset by this and despite all his talk
about addressing the concerns of the
whales he understands that he's talking
crap he wants the Dow to give him money
the anonymous whales in question do not
want him to receive money there is no
negotiating or compromising just
pharaohs you can pray to so that leads
us naturally onto the subject of the
Dows management the Dow has been speed
running bureaucratic paralysis in 2020
they attempted to automate governance by
running an on-chain system but it didn't
work no one wanted to pay transaction
costs to vote on every name ban and
point of Interest so they moved the
system back off chains six months later
problem is that without automation you
need humans to push the buttons
decentraland is quite proud of the Dow's
Grant scheme but it's been a massive
headache for them recently for the first
year they gave away 3.5 million dollars
in Grants to develop projects that would
Aid adoption but the Grant application
had no standard process and grants had
no oversight and no accountability
because no one existed with the
authority to do it the initial proposal
alluded to the idea of revoking grants
but included no framework to implement
it so the Dow committee put forward a
proposal to set up a squad whose job
would be to help grantees deliver their
product and in extreme in cases where a
project had collapsed or was too far off
course the squad could recommend that
the committee revoke the grant but the
committee is Administrative they can't
revoke the Grant and the squad are
essentially independent contractors they
can't revoke the grant either so we need
a new committee with express permission
to revoke grants enter the grant
revocation committee we could go crazy
with dissecting this but the short
version is that these committees are
meant to have minimal discretion the
authors of the policy seem to think that
discretion only exists if you
acknowledge it so rather than limiting
the scope of consideration like any
other discretionary position in
government they limit the committee to
only considering cases that are actively
handed to them but put no restraints on
the committee members actual decision
making
effectively giving them Absolute Power
to revoke any grant for any reason and
as the cherry on top there's no appeals
process because to appeal the verdict
would require a different group with the
authority to overturn the decision of
the revocation committee the committee
intended to have minimal discretion is
completely unrestrained with zero
accountability oh and and these guys are
paid commission for every verdict so the
Dow is about to learn real fast why we
don't do that in the real world then we
have the facilitation Squad the
governance Squad the protocol Squad the
security Advisory Board the newly
proposed working groups they're
expanding the Dow committee from three
to five members but only after an
election to replace one of the original
Three in Trying to minimize human
involvement they have instead ballooned
it and like look at the participation
numbers generously there's a few hundred
people actively involved in the Dow in
any capacity at all and at this rate
every single one of them is going to be
in at least one squad or work group or
realistically the couple dozen people
with the inclination to spend their free
time role-playing bureaucrats are going
to be sitting on the accountability
Squad that has oversight over the
oversight work group that advises the
spending Council on how much the
accountability Squad should be paid oh
and these bureaucrats are paid in Mana
which as we've seen is a direct source
of political power like do you remember
that time yaml agreed with yaml that
yaml should be paid 150 an hour in Mana
would you be shocked to learn that yemel
who agreed with yaml about paying yaml
150 an hour is friends with Malik and
ordano from back in the days when they
all spent their time at a tech bro Flop
House they called Casa Voltaire and
through all this bureaucratic garbage
it's easy to lose sight of the truth the
Dow has no actual Authority decentraland
isn't owned by its users it's owned by
its owners the foundation while the
foundation seeds the copyright on
materials submitted by users the terms
of use make it very clear that the
foundation holds the copyright on the
decentraland part of decentraland as
Catalina go on to points out this
conflicts with the rhetoric that
decentraland is owned by its users when
the most significant legal right in this
area is unambiguously owned by the
foundation even looking past that can it
really be said that decentraland is
owned by its users when the Dow is
currently being held hostage by a dozen
whales whose proportional voting rights
dwarf their peers now being a digital
landlord doesn't require much engagement
at all I would Hazard that whoever owns
50 identical decentraland homes
plastered with for sale advertisements
isn't really a decentraland user above
the most literal threshold I on the
other hand am demonstrably a user of
decentraland given how dead engagement
is I feel pretty confident in estimating
that I spend far more hours per year
actively looking around and doing stuff
in the world than the median landowner
but I am not an owner of decentraland by
virtue of that time spent in the world
there is no mechanism that correlates
the two that gives ownership to those
who use it and strips ownership from
those who idly hoard the mechanism of
ownership is not usage it's ownership of
land and Mana The Arc of decentralized
development is dictated by the
foundation they may occasionally ask the
Dao what features they'd like to see or
act on simple proposals for technical
changes but the Dao is not
decentraland's board of directors well
first first I think that the central
land is always working with the
community because we are a doll right
right as a decentralized platform we are
mostly governed by the Dao so we are not
a corporation so our roadmap also
operates differently because we always
try to look into what the community is
aiming so notice how she doesn't say
we're Bound by the decisions of the Dow
because there are bosses instead the
foundation is working with the community
and trying to look into where the
community is aiming when discussing
decentralized perspective value to
actual business the foundation can't say
with a straight face that
representatives from Target need to get
in touch with the Dow facilitation Squad
to outline the contents of a proposal at
a certain point all the talk of
decentralized ownership and political
revolution needs to get put aside so
Dolce and Gabbana will actually respond
to the emails and line goes up we all
had a good laugh at Dao's whose Central
product was undefined are we a comic
book or a bi-monthly curated box of
snacks but to their credit that is in
keeping with philosophy of a Dao in the
case of decentraland the foundation came
first and knows what it is and what it
wants to be if the Tao were to vote for
the project to become a 2d metroidvania
set in a hypothetical fourth Punic War
in the visual style of NHL 94 sorry that
isn't happening the foundation acts
autonomously whenever it wants when the
foundation implemented the First ATM in
the metaverse they didn't consult the
Dow before starting development and can
you blame them can you imagine if as a
business they were Bound by the whims of
these losers despite the rhetoric the
foundation isn't dependent on the Dao in
truth it's the opposite the Dao can't
function without the foundation not just
in the obvious ways but from top to
bottom the 2021 proposal to go off chain
came from the executive director of
decentraland in The Proposal he
nominated three individuals to serve as
the administrative committee members all
of whom were working at the foundation
at the time the point is the
decentraland Dao simply lacks the means
to function autonomously through lack of
tools unimaginable inequality General
incompetence and the lack of authority
the Dao is impotent so is it any wonder
that their Grant scheme can turn 240
000 US Dollars into the metagamma mall I
mean what else could this system
possibly produce
one of the most telling moments in the
decentralized timeline is the June 2019
blog post announcing the switch from The
Babylon engine to Unity not because of
the engine change in and of itself but
because of this note jumping added
jumping puzzles it's important to note
are functionally the single ludic
interaction inherent to decentralized
mechanics the only games that you see in
the world with any consistency games
that actually involve interacting with
the space and not with a two-dimensional
UI element are scavenger hunts and
jumping puzzles unless you're headed to
the gambling Halls jumping on things is
functionally the only thing to
consistently do in decentraland and it
was this is important an afterthought
2019 that's four years of development
before jumping was added as basic
functionality Ari melick and Esteban
ordano are Argentine developers who met
in a hacker house known as Casa Voltaire
most of what we know about castle
Voltaire comes from two online articles
one from 2017 and another from 2020.
cassaval Terror Hit The Sweet Spot of
anonymity there's not really any
contemporary information about what was
going on there because it was just a
flop house for Tech Bros but it left
just enough of a footprint to become
mythologized the community at the
villase castle became a worldwide Legend
a crazy hacker Haven for cryptocurrency
projects as Ryan vanzo describes it the
house was a communal workspace where
small startups would operate in the
house and share resources and expertise
this was combined with a heady blend of
smart boy philosophy both of the
previously mentioned articles paint a
picture of Genius citing the Deep
conversations that would take place
within the group but you know here's the
Deep moral dilemmas vanzo cites in his
story how should autonomous cars act in
a situation that would save the driver
but kill a pedestrian who is liable if a
bot malfunctions and causes harm what
kind of neurosecurity should we develop
to protect users of brain to brain
interfaces so like a high school
introduction to ethics one of those is
literally the trolley problem in this
environment and within the context of
Argentina's political volatility or Dano
and Malik conceived of decentraland as a
bunch of things principally a
fulfillment of the fantasy of snow crash
The Matrix and of course Ready Player
One the idea was basically whether we
could do a virtual world that was based
on opens standards and blockchain and
whether we could encode the physics into
into a blockchain of course influenced
by
videos and movies like Matrix Ready
Player one and so snow crash but inside
of that was an inkling of the political
the notion that this could be a test bed
for political movements for new
economies and ideally Liberation
movements writing for rest of the world
Leo Schwartz and Lucia cholaki and
Herrera describe it skeptically as a
petri dish for the ideals of democracy
and decentralization they championed
built on the premise that a virtual
world controlled by its own citizens
could more effectively govern itself and
offer more stable investment
opportunities than a real one governed
by Elites
of course in actuality decentraland is
steered exclusively by its own Elites
people who bought in hard and early and
have the voting power to dismiss any
challenge to their power or literal
project insiders who have the social
capital and access to the code base to
Simply and run the will of the whales
because decentraland is not a petri dish
sterilized and sealed off from our
reality in 2003 writers rushed to
Harold's second life as the Vanguard of
the future not just a video game but a
new place that couldn't have existed
before two years prior Edward castranova
had argued that EverQuest and virtual
worlds like it were important because
the objects in them were worth money in
response to Second Life castronova
predicted that in the future Humanity
would pick the virtual world over the
real The Exodus of people from The Real
World from our normal daily life of
living rooms cubicles and shopping malls
will create a chain in Social climate
that makes global warming look like a
tempest in a teacup Philip Rosedale a
developer on Second Life went even
further the real world will become like
a museum very soon so it'll be
fantastically cool to go to New York but
in the same way that it's cool to go see
the Mayan ruins because the big
buildings will still be there but
they'll be covered in dust because no
one will bother too much with them
anymore there's just one tiny almost
inconsequential problem here just a
little thing we'll talk about it in a
moment here but maybe just keep in your
mind that there's a small little issue
Johan Hua Zinga is known for his
Landmark anthropological work homo
ludens published in 1938. huizinga was
concerned with the interaction between
play and culture and a key element of
that was trying to Define play what is
the difference between a fight and a
play fight how is it that talk on grass
can produce a boundary that people take
seriously during a game of soccer
hozinga proposed the concept of the
magic circle which aims to describe how
play Space is delineated from The
Ordinary World in a game of Dungeons and
Dragons the rules and instructions alone
aren't enough to represent the entire
game world it is the compound
relationship of formal social dramatic
and aesthetic elements essentially when
you buy into the game everything comes
together to create a kind of pocket
Dimension a psychological bubble where
board pieces dice rolls and social
interactions can take on unique meanings
distinct from reality in a game of
soccer the players all agree to obey the
rules of the game and a social contract
forms suddenly the ball chalk and their
own limbs take on properties prescribed
to them in the player's mind boundaries
become respectable and in respecting
them they become real if however someone
one then karate chops the opposing
goalie in the throat the bubble bursts
the contract has been broken the circle
has been pierced and the lines on the
ground stop mattering real fast in an
honest engagement where the fiction is
unavoidably present but elighted for the
sake of immersion we would call the
circle suspension of disbelief or k-fob
Tom belsdorf and Edward castranova both
sought to push Second Life as a real
place separate from the real world where
genuine research could be done
bellstorff argued that second life was a
fixed site of culture like a Pacific
island Edward castranova made a career
out of arguing that second life was a
site of genuine economic activity they
not in their words but in criticism
present second life as existing within
an impermeable magic circle as like the
Matrix somewhere you travel to a place
okay but there's just that one tiny
minuscule problem problem and that's the
people who live in Second Life don't
actually live in Second Life you can eat
an infinite amount of digital food in
virtual reality and you will still
starve but the metaverse both presumes
and requires that legitimacy of place
and the real either the outright
reification of Ryan Bulger or digital
fashion being pushed as a genuine
property it needs to be real in order to
be meaningful so the authors of
decentraland it's creators and its users
paint a magic circle around it with a
narrative of inevitability a narrative
of the metaverse A Narrative of a true
separate new world that you will
eventually move your life into because
if your neighbors aren't going to
eventually be compelled to be here
tomorrow why would you ever want this
today decentraland is at every level a
collective fairy tale just people
playing pretend
gels was that we
whether it be the pedigree Foster versus
scraping data from adoptapet users
playing lawyer in their Corporate
Offices or purporting to be the future
of news decentralized value to
businesses is patently absurd and as
we've seen even its decentralized
premise is a fantasy the Dow has no
Authority and is comically hapless
content to play politics all the while
pretending that they have a stake in a
billion dollar product and it's not
enough to convince themselves they need
to convince you so that is what they do
by any means necessary they will Pander
mislead outright lie whatever it takes
for you to buy into their narrative
because this only makes sense from
inside the circle
[Music]
the virtual world
create the up and trade Without Limits
make genuine connections and earn real
money decentraland is a farce and a
tragedy it is painted into a corner by a
combination of ineptitude and inherently
bad ideas and it cannot Escape its
fundamental being whatever other ideals
are spit out whatever rhetoric about
Liberation or political experimentation
is employed the simple fact that it was
materially born as a pre-sale of lots of
land based on a fiction of people moving
in sets off a chain of decisions and
incentives about design and
functionality that bind it forever to
being little more than a fantasy real
estate scheme an endless world of
uniquely scarce dead malls
[Music]
I can't use that right now
thank you
if I can't use that right now
I can't use that right now
[Music]
Mighty kind of you
if I can't use that right now
I can't use that right now
[Music]
oh my God what did you do
I can't use that right now